This is Radiolab.
You are Robert Krulwich and you're Jad
Abumrad and today our topic on radiolab
is sleep. Yep. It is something that
all of us do. We can't help but do it.
It's dangerous to do. It's so good
and it's universal. I think about it,
you know,
sleep is dangerous and if sleep could
have been circumvented in some way,
natural selection probably
would have found a way to do it.
But Steve Lima again from Indiana State
University. Yeah, it because it would,
it just, it'd be such a great idea
to not sleep, don't I know it,
but there are times when
you just can't sleep. Right.
Maybe you're one of the
35 million Americans I am.
Who has chronic insomnia.
Yeah. You just can't sleep.
You don't know why it just doesn't happen.
Or maybe you do it to yourself and you
pull all nighters for school or you have
to drive long distances or,
and here's what we want to
turn our attention to next.
Maybe it is done to you.
That's the case with
producer Hannah Palin.
She kept this audio diary of her own
experiment with sleep deprivation.
She has an 18 month old son.
It's two 54 for the record.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
today was my first day back at work.
We were discussing budgets. I just,
I just,
I couldn't even articulate what it was
that I was seeing on the computer screen
and try to communicate that to
the curator that I work for.
The words didn't come
down on me instead of
saying, well, Nicolette,
I believe that that choice
was made because no, no.
All that came out was like,
um, honey buckets. I mean,
nothing, nothing would come out.
There's just no brain cells really.
Wow. So anyway,
that was my first day back at work.
[inaudible]
where do you stop it Dominic? Well,
not sleep.
I'm trying to get him to sleep
and kind of at my wit's end
cut. This just sucks. It totally sucks.
Here's the funny thing.
Everybody has a theory,
and I was talking to my sister in law
tonight and her theory is that he's not
getting enough milk because milk has some
agent in it that would help him sleep
and he doesn't like milk. It's true.
Other people say, Oh, if
he just read exercise him,
if he just gets fresh air and
exercise, he'll sleep all night.
If he just let him cry,
would sleep all night if you just would
do whatever it is we're not doing.
He would sleep all night.
Okay. And there's this feeling like
there's a feeling like I am doing it
all wrong and that I'm a failure as a
parent and I don't know how to do this.
Come here sweetie. Come on.
Come on. Come on. Come on.
So anyway,
I needed to record just one thing really
quickly and that is that yesterday and
today I've been struck by fantastic.
I'm instructed by these waves of
satisfaction and delight with being
alive in this amazing landscape with
the funny kid [inaudible]
mountains and, and water.
And I don't know,
maybe it's just getting a little more
sleep in the last couple of days,
but I suddenly feel
like, wow, I'm so lucky.
Okay, I've got to take my
kid to play now. Here we go.
Do you know the Muffin
man? The muffin man?
[inaudible] okay. That
whole I'm loving life.
Yeah. That's all gone now.
And it's pretty much because
Dominic won't take a nap.
We came home from the beach, which
I thought would wear him out.
Then we sat down and read some
stories, which for some reason,
and I realized that an element to the
sleep deprivation and an element to this
whole thing is that I get angry from
having my own needs subverted to the needs
of this little tiny person,
which when you're not sleep
deprived is not a big deal.
Oh, tired. I tired. I don't cry.
[inaudible]
I don't want to wish a minute of Dominic's
childhood away cause it's so precious
to me. But I,
I'm looking forward to,
uh, that moment when,
um, I am able to say, honey, I have to
go to sleep and he does it die here?
No, not die. [inaudible]
eyes. Your Eyes Buck. Okay.
Close your eye.
There's my personal take on what it's
like to be sleepy and to crave sleep as
much as you crave water
or breath. I crave it.
Thanks to Hannah Palin and her son,
Dominick and her husband Steve.
I know poor Hannah, but there is a science
question looking in the background,
which is when you know,
when Hannah was so tired,
why does she feel that way?
You know what? W W what?
Because she's, she hasn't been sleeping.
Oh yeah, but, but what makes her,
you know, what is the essence of
tiredness? Lack of sleep. Hello?
Chemically, I'm asking you chemicals.
What is it happening to her?
If you were way down in herself, could
you see something tired like going on?
That's what I, that's a
good question actually.
I'm glad you think so because I know
a guy who has a theory about this.
Did you see Tiger yesterday? [inaudible]
of antibody. I mean,
the guy is unbelievable.
This is doctor gallon pack and in
addition to being a rabid golf fan,
he's also a rabid, but can you
be a rabid biologist? Sure.
At the University of Pennsylvania,
he's been looking at sleep down at the
cellular level and one thing that he's
found over and over and over,
and that's been shown in Moses has been
shown in rise, been shown in fruit fly,
is that inside certain cells
in all those different animals,
when they're sleep deprived and Shelly,
what happens is you don't get
proteins properly for all the,
excuse me,
proteins properly folded a phenomenon
called the unfolded protein response.
What on Earth does that mean? Is
that a good thing or a bad thing you,
you're asking why do you need
proteins to properly fold? Yeah,
I guess that's what I'm asking.
Well, you are made of proteins.
Proteins are the essence of you.
So if your proteins are misshapen,
if they're not folded properly,
don't fold the proteins properly.
They don't have the right three
dimensional structure, and as a result,
they start accumulating inside the
cell and then these different unfolded
proteins can aggregate
together and front clump.
Whoops.
Inside the cell and essentially clog it
up and it's really quite toxic to cells.
Clumpiness equals tiredness
as would be his formula.
Remember when Hannah was
so exhausted? Yeah. God,
this just sucks. Well, because she
hasn't slept much inside herself.
Lots of these valuable little proteins
have not folded properly that he thinks
is the consequence of
not having enough sleep.
So maybe what's going on is the cells
can't do their business quite as well and
things start to break down and that adds
up across the whole of your body to a
fueling. But when she gets to sleep,
remember when she's so happy, suddenly
feel like, wow, because of the sleep,
I'm so lucky. A group of cleaning
reppers have gone through herself,
removed the toxic and misshapen
proteins so that in effect,
sleep is the best housemaid you've
ever had in the hotel. Have you,
and this idea, the,
the idea of sleep as a cleaner wrapper
might even explain one of the most basic
things about us as humans, how we learn.
That's the notion of doctor Giulio
Tononi testing, testing, testing.
My producer Ellen Horn and I went to
visit him at his offices in Madison,
Wisconsin.
What are we expecting? What does he
look like? We don't know what else,
like pop player, a football
player, but like a quarter backer.
Tight end. Not like a
so big but not overwhelming. Yes. Yeah.
How do you even know
that website? See, but
totally wrong. Now, to be fair,
he is a very attractive guy, has
sandy blonde hair and glasses,
so he's actually the more that sensitive
guy intellectual than a linebacker.
Okay. Introduce yourself.
I'm Julia [inaudible].
I am a professional psychiatry here at
the University of Wisconsin Madison,
but when it comes to the subject
of sleep, which is his specialty,
he takes sleep very seriously.
Like what got you didn't sleep.
Sleep is the annihilation
of consciousness,
so it's a terrible time in
which everything disappears.
The universe and yourself with it.
I think if people didn't sleep and
didn't have the unconscious sleep,
they possibly wouldn't even realize
that consciousness is an enormous gift.
So being awake then is wonderful, but
it's what happens when you're asleep.
He says that's what allows you to make
very important connections in your life.
And he noticed this first, you may
train when he was connecting with the,
I believe it was a guitar, just playing
music. I used to play, for instance,
I played classical guitar.
I'm sure many people who play musical
instruments know that you may train and
train and train on a piece during
the day and you get better for sure,
but you're never perfect. Oh,
and then you sleep over it
the next day you wake up,
you play it again and now it's smooth
and you know it flows. Beautiful.
That happened. Yeah,
it happened to me. It
happens to lots of people.
That happened to me all the time.
I discovered that sometimes if I
worked on a piece and put it away,
I went to bed and cut some rust.
I had it better learned than if
I stayed up all night cramming.
Yeah, definitely. There's one story,
and I hadn't thought about this for a
long time, but, well first of all, Robin,
I like play in a band together.
The band is called the sisterhood
of convoluted thinkers and we switch
instruments like a lot. She's
usually the bass player.
I was going to play drums, I
had to learn how to play drums.
So we rented a cabin,
we went somewhere to rehearse and
at night she was really just kind of
practicing and practicing and trying to
get this written one in particular be
like, I've worked on it like a lot.
I just keep going and going and replaying
that one thing again and again and
again.
And I finally just gave up and went to
sleep and the next morning I got up and
went like straight to the kid and
I just played it like immediately.
The bucket, the stool,
she was going [inaudible]
you could just do it.
I thought it was magic or you could
just learn stuff in your sleep.
So wait,
they were showing the middle of the night
somehow the things that your fingers
did repeatedly and the notes that you
were using to propel your fingers.
All those things somehow
got into that more.
Got Better learned. So you
learned overnight or you,
I mean what does have to do with it or
you remember better in the morning? No.
What happens is that the next day you're
a bit better off what happens during
the night to make you better off.
This is up for contention to nannies.
Contention is that sleep helps
you remember by forgetting
and I don't know what
that means. Let me explain
to you what he, what he say.
He says there's a limited
amount of space in your brain.
The real estate in the brain speed limit,
unlimited amount and makes sense as
a small little guy up there. Yup.
And yet every experience you have during
the day he's going to take away some
space, uses up a little of what
you got when you are awake.
Inevitably you learn
whether you want it or not.
You are going round talking to
me. Okay. I was having breakfast,
have a medium coffee, going to work,
then yakking on the phone with the you
went. Your friends pop into your mind.
Very different from from the friends.
Then going home, taking a bath,
they'll take a bath. I get it again.
Everything you do during the day,
every thought you think,
no matter how small,
it all causes your brain
to form new connections.
This conversation as we're
having it is reshaping my brain.
A little pathways are forming that
weren't there before I sat down exactly
whether we recognize it or not.
Lots of things I go on to change your
brain by the end of the Waking Day.
So if in the middle of the afternoon
you sit down with your guitar and you
practice the guitar
intently, those two hours,
you're also making connections
and because you're concentrating,
maybe you're making more
connections than usual.
These are guitar connections and all
those synaptic connections made during the
day. Wow. Just have a meeting [inaudible]
by the time you're ready,
I'm ready for sleep up in your
kitchen.
[inaudible]
and that is where we think sleep kicks
in. Well, I'm going to guess here,
but I think you think that sleep is a
garbage detail that comes into is okay,
you're done. You're done. You're done.
It's actually even simpler than that.
According to Noni, there's not really a
janitor who comes in and decides, okay,
you have to leave. You get to stay.
Nothing like that. Instead he says,
what happens?
We think that doing sleep
waves of electrical activity,
kind of like a late evening
bath wash over your head.
They start at the back of your
head. I mean you move to the front.
These waves are called slow or salacious
and the course of the night 1000 times
a night, those waves wash through
all the experiences of your day,
all the little synaptic connections that
you made all day long and every one of
those connections, all of that
gets just a little bit softer.
They get weaker progressively, gracefully.
They get weaker even he says the things
you want to hold onto like the guitar.
Wait a second. Wait a second.
You are the one who said you learned
how to play the instrument in the
afternoon. You went to sleep and you play
the instrument better in the morning.
Yep. Why would you wake up the
next morning playing better?
You should play more weekly with
less confidence and less memory.
Because after all, you've just given the
whole place a bath. It's all relative,
sir. What he means by relative is this,
that that mass of new
connections in your head.
Some of those connections are softer.
Some of those connections were louder.
The random things you ordered for lunch,
they're softer. Okay? But the guitar,
cause you spend so much time
thinking about guitar technique,
you spend so much energy
on it. That's louder.
So we're just measuring connections here.
Now imagine that sleep is a big volume
na so listen to what happens when you
lower the volume on the whole day
and lower.
You hear how the softer stuff just falls
away. You can't hear it anymore. Yeah.
Bad. The Guitar, while
it's getting softer too,
because it was so loud to begin with,
now it stands out a bit more clearly now.
Yeah. The signal seems to
have survived reasonably well,
are heard better because the
background has become more silent.
So your ability to play the guitar better
the next morning is not because you've
learned these skills overnight that you
didn't have before is because all the
other stuff taken up.
Your brain has gone down in volume and
you're left with relatively speaking,
a better guitar fingering technique.
You put your finger on it.
So Mr Schenone feels that sleep is a
little bit like we didn't rain like the
process of erosion at the end of the day,
or rather at the beginning of the morning,
the things left standing are
the things you need to know.
We should, uh, we should
go to break. Okay.
So coming up next for those of
us who can get this leap next,
our change to dream. This is radio lab.
I'm Chad, I'm rod and I rapid rolling.
We'll continue in a moment.